I read all of the summaries of your
projects and your backgrounds and
recognize that most of you are not going
to be working on Central and Eastern
Europe but um what i will do is try to
place it in some kind of comparative
perspective for those of you who are
much more interested in Eurasia I in
fact them an old Soviet specialist so I
worked on both Eastern Europe and the
Soviet Union during communism and I
still maintain an interest in Russia and
particularly the Caucasus area what I
thought I'd do and it was hard to know
what would be most useful for you and
I'm really happy to be interrupted with
questions etc although because they're
taping this I'm not allowed to walk
around I kind of like to act more like a
talk show host when I'm talking enough
I'm Park as I don't hear well but in
part because I hate it be rooted in one
place but anyway we'll move on but what
I thought I'd do is is do a very quick
historical discussion that moves back
and forth between some events in the
region um and the ways in which people
analyze them and one of the things I
think that's important in talking about
this is to understand that what was
going on in the region what people
worked on didn't necessarily correlate
all that well and so what people chose
to focus on the development of the study
of Eastern Europe had a life of its own
not surprisingly as well as being rooted
in in various things going on we just
say a few words briefly about the the
interwar period because I think that
what was interesting about the the
interwar period in Eastern European
studies are a couple of things I wanted
to emphasize one of course is that that
is the beginning of the theme that we
see over and over again in Eastern and
Central Europe that is to say the
simultaneous construction of state's new
economies and new regimes
it's also the beginning of we can do
this from above in effect we can
engineer the transformation of this
region it also brings open the theme of
Eastern Europe did not have control
uneasy the old-fashioned term here did
not have any control over what happened
to it that it was situated as it is
today between some very big players that
had excuse me enormous impact on on what
happened in the region and so the work
on the region I think and it was done
more by British scholars than by
American scholars in the interwar period
and the British scholars were
interestingly enough also very tuned in
which they continued after the Second
World War with issues of nationalism and
they also had frankly the language
training that the American scholars did
not and of course there was the
historical engagement of the british
empire in the region among other things
sort of ancillary to the issue of the
great game and the struggles among
empires the breakup of the Ottoman
Empire the longest dying Empire one can
imagine and how that affected British
British politics but what I wanted to
emphasize about the interwar period
that's interesting to me at least in
rethinking about it is how many of the
issues came back after communism and how
many of the same sets of debates the
same sets of issues kept returning what
I've already said obviously about how do
you build new States how do you do that
simultaneously with new regimes and new
economies can you in fact structure a
whole economy from the top and a whole
regime from the top as opposed to an
evolutionary model which the West often
had the luxury of having in part because
of where Eastern Europe was in great
ways in which it absorbed the shocks and
the problems of the larger region within
which it was in case but also this is
the beginning of the debate over Civic
and ethnic nationalism is really in the
interwar period on nationalism defined
by territory
versus nationalism defined by something
more fundamental and basic having to do
with genetics whatever kinds of things
so that is an issue that pops up another
issue that pops up in interwar studies
that we see again this Democratic
breakdown not just transitions to
democracy which is what the 1920s were
about in much of eastern and central
europe but also democratic breakdown by
the end of the 1920s many of the debates
that surrounded democratic breakdown in
most of these countries with exception
obviously of czechoslovakia though the
slow locks argue there was a democratic
breakdown as far as they noticed but the
checks didn't seem to really notice that
in the interwar experience but many of
the debates are the same the
artificiality of democracy the problem
of the wrong class structure for
democracy the problem of development for
democracy large peasant classes for
democracy um the problem of bad
institutional design which made it easy
among other things for for democratic
institutions to work badly and open up
for possibilities of political coup
d'etats like insertions of the military
in politics so I'm bringing this up
because I think it is important to see
the repetitious character of the issues
that in the interwar period the struggle
was very similar in terms of what people
were working on to the struggle that we
find after communism okay let me say a
few words again please feel free to
interrupt me I'm rushing through things
very very quickly let me say a few words
about the rise of communism and just say
that this is when of course Eastern
European studies becomes infused with
enormous political baggage how people
understood you know you could come up
with an easy story that fit very well
into the Cold War understanding of
things which was that the Red Army had
to get to Berlin and the way to do that
was in effect to take over all of
Eastern Europe on the way but what we
know is a much more complicated story
and in terms of research
that is important I think to put out
there at least briefly and that was the
Red Army had a plan for some places and
not for others number one number two
there were significant differences
domestically excuse me significant
differences domestically in political
support not just for democracy but also
on the left what the left wanted and so
to understand one way to think about
many countries I think an Eastern and
Central Europe at the time and there's a
wonderful novel ashes and diamonds i
think that captures this very well is
that no one knew where they were going
and there wasn't a natural consensus
that existed given the inner war
experience and the horrible experiences
of World War two it was like a big
pillow waiting in many ways to be
punched in excuse me I know how would
you do this rumor shall dig go um okay
so so that's that's one important there
was a lot of variation there was a lot
of variation local support they were
also variation and how it happened how
quickly it happened quick and romania
slow in czechoslovakia etc so the real
point here for people who worked on the
region was trying to get beyond a kind
of simplistic understanding to deal with
the complexity of the individual eastern
european cases this was also complicated
by the rush into the field of migrs
scholars some of whom had specific
access to grind and some of whom were
able to step back and have very rich
analyses of what was going on but it
also introduced another issue which i
think the study of eastern and central
europe struggled with for a long time
and that is was it simply an appendage
of soviet studies or was it something in
its own right that could be that could
be analyzed
now let me turn because I think it is
important to remember communism and the
Communist experience and I mean that for
two reasons I'm a political scientist so
of course I'm skewing all this much more
towards a kind of a political
understanding of the important variables
and Michael Kennedy will keep me honest
by reminding me that there is something
called sociology among other things but
but what is what is really important
about remembering communism I think
personally is that it simply been erased
from social scientists understanding of
authoritarianism it is to me remarkable
how fickle and present oriented social
scientists are there is a huge outgrowth
which some of you may be aware of a huge
growing interest in authoritarianism
amongst among political scientists as
well as for that matter economists
people who do formal work as well and
the Communist experience is missing
completely as though it never happened
and you could say well you know it's
dead in most places but the important
thing is that it is a part of
authoritarianism it alerts us to
contemporary authoritarianism because of
the comparative standard it provides and
I've been very very concerned about this
issue and having a coat each of course
on authoritarianism with a young
colleague of mine who might dearly love
who was trained to Stanford and who
thinks that leaders get up and
manipulate everything and there's
individual rationality and blah blah
blah because that's the way he was
trained but when I say well we need to
have readings on communism it you know
why and some of you may know for example
stevehopkins book on magnitogorsk which
i think is a great book but one of the
things is really wonderful about it is
that reminds you of two things that were
very important in understanding
communism the missionary zeal and the
chaos despite the planning you know and
if those are the two themes I see in the
magnetic course book the kind of
unbelievable ambitions of this project
purportedly planned and truly chaotic on
the ground I you know the more ambitious
the more chaotic perhaps one could argue
almost as a hypothesis but at any rate
just a side step on on the issue of
authoritarianism better let me say that
you know i was thinking back on the
evolution of all communist and then of
course most of us who worked in the
field i am old enough to have spent not
quite half my career on communism so of
course i also miss it um in certain ways
but well you know all the stupid things
i had to know and it seems like i should
get to trot out just at least a little
bit of those dumb things that i had to
know like prejudice scientific technical
revolution i mean boy though that was a
gripping drama it was just really deadly
but at any rate there is some there was
important things to understand i think
about the evolution of of communism and
and and much of that was really captured
much more frankly I'm someone who
straddled Soviet and European studies
and often worked on Soviet bloc
relations as well as doing some work on
on Yugoslavia relations and what was
interesting about work on Eastern and
Central Europe or recalled at Eastern
Europe then is that it was much much
more sensitive to change much more one
might also argue to be fair interested
in the possibility of change one to keep
us awake Brezhnev was it really deadly
but the second thing was that it it
generated research agenda for people if
you thought the system wasn't moving or
going anywhere nothing was happening
there were no tensions it was a
well-oiled machine that didn't really
change over time then you know what do
you work on but what happened I think is
that is that in in Eastern European
studies first of all there were things
that may enriched it much more than
Soviet studies I think and one is that
we had multiple cases now people who
worked on the Soviet Union did do
comparisons of Soviet republics for
example but frankly the database for
that was really skimpy you know it was
very hard to get to those places it was
very hard to collect information about
them and in the like and it was and
there were some studies I remember like
Joel Moses a few others of local
politics in the Soviet Union but it was
hard to get there so one is that you had
a lot more cases so you could compare
them and you were sensitive to the fact
that communism meant different things in
different places you know that polish
communism was not Romanian communism and
one of the great lines about remaining
communism socialism in one family um
that that was very close to you know a
person very personalized dictatorship
but it had to do with how much state
control and ownership there was in the
economy it had to do actually with how
large and inclusive the Communist Party
was it had to do with the area of room
for media and personal maneuver the
possibility of a kind of a civil society
versus the not possibility of such a
thing and the like you know they're very
different patterns of political
mobilization you know East Germany
Czechoslovakia Poland and Yugoslavia
with the protesting cases the others
were not so much although you saw began
to c minor strikes towards the end and
in last 10 years or so in romania and
the like but what I'm trying to
emphasize here is that in a way there
several issues Eastern European studies
was very sensitive to issues and very
interested in issues of autonomy from
the party state carving out autonomy
mobilizing against the party state
apparatus locating areas of greater
freedom of maneuver that also meant that
most of the work in the field was on the
more liberal regimes which tolerated
this for a variety of different reasons
that is to say most of us worked on
Poland Hungary and you just love you
very few people worked on Czechoslovakia
because after 1968 it was pretty
shutdown
very hard to do things they had so
called normalization and that tightened
the regime even though there was the end
of killing people who disagreed with the
party state at the same time no economic
reform and very few liberalizing
political reforms none actually in in
Czechoslovakia where's Poland hungry and
Yugoslavia you could do research you
could go there you could actually talk
to academics who are doing research you
couldn't do that in Moscow you really
could not I mean I think about going
between Poland going to in Warsaw and
Moscow it was night and day it was
absolutely night and day you simply just
you didn't have the infrastructure of
people you know research the openness of
the system etc to really do nearly as
much so what happened i think at under
communism it's not just that Eastern
Europe became the antechamber of
innovation and pressures were changed
within the Soviet bloc as did you go
slavia of course which was not really in
the block but it also transformed the
two sets of studies in really important
ways Eastern European studies was more
diverse more interested in change more
interested again in protest or interest
in party state versus society relations
and Soviet studies was much more
interested in the elite what the elite
were doing what they were working on how
they were organized etc now let me say a
few words about evidence here because it
is it is interesting um I think how did
we figure out during communism how do we
have the foot spa to write things where
we had such poor access you know that's
what I always look back on in blush you
know and think I knew so little and I
wrote that it's just it's just
terrifying because when communism
collapsed suddenly you had access in a
way that you just didn't have before but
what did you use for for information
well I mean basically you used a variety
of indicators from which you could
extrapolate logical things
for example speeches if you saw
differences in speeches you could assume
that and by the top leadership you could
assume that there were tensions within
the leadership and debates within the
leadership and these things especially
since they buried over time you know
meant that you could get some kind of
sense of expansion contraction of
intra-party conflict a lot of work I did
a lot of people did was on looking at
policies and using those policies to
extrapolate backwards to what kinds of
politics what kinds of economics would
produce such policies so so that was the
it was a very indirect method of trying
to get at what was going on let me also
say in continuing this theme of looking
at Soviet vs eastern european studies
there were some other interesting
differences not just what we've worked
on and all that stuff eastern european
studies was smaller field it was more
ideologically diverse you had people all
over the ideological map there was some
degree of that also in soviet studies
although maybe mark wood I'm both not
going to agree with me more in history
than in political science i would say um
you know in history i would make a
different generalization about the
ideological side more mix positions on
the regime's um people were writing on
you know why these regimes will always
adore and they were writing on why
they're going to fall tomorrow and so
that was interesting another interesting
thing this was really true I thought
about this a lot for some reason Eastern
European studies was much more female
than Soviet studies much more I remember
because I went to both set to
conferences and i can tell you you know
all those guys you know the bombs and
bullets and everything I mean you know
this was there they were doing a super
power and we were just doing the piddly
little empire
and so it's an if there was a very clear
distinction um and and if you think back
on it it's hard to come up with many
major female specialists on the Soviet
Union nah now you know condi rice came
in at the last minute she was late in
the game Gail Lapidus it's hard to come
up with many whereas in Eastern European
studies you can just there a lot there
were a lot so we can think about why
that might be i won't i won't belabor it
but it's interesting but as i said more
comparative more disciplinary influenced
I don't know Tim fry what is Tim been
here yet is he coming yeah Tim might you
don't want it don't hit me for this one
but but I think that um Eastern European
studies was just much more ready for the
collapse full stop why was that well one
we've been doing change we've been doing
dissident communities we and and some of
us had had this this person had
published an article which made people
extremely mad at me in Eastern Europe
saying that the Soviets audit dumped
Eastern Europe because it was sucking
the blood out of the Soviet Union but of
course put it much nicer social science
terminology about the cost of empire for
the Soviet Union and its dominance over
over Eastern Europe but we were
imagining tensions contradictions exits
we were imagining challenges writing
about those challenges and and like and
we were also i think more connected to
disciplinary discussions of transitions
to democracy and issues like that when
you do a superpower when you do the big
one you have an enormous amount invested
and that big ones staying around and
that big one being there forever or
moreover you know I'm frankly I mean
superpowers just don't usually actually
let alone implode I mean that isn't the
usual way history plays out but the
point is that they were also very much
focusing on the
restate the other interesting thing I'll
just say you know that it was always
fascinated to me I often went from the
Soviet Union to Eastern Europe during
communism and virtually no Soviet
specialists did that and if they did
that they would have seen very clearly
how disastrous the Soviet economy was
you go to Moscow and as a Russian friend
of mine said my god is a third-world
country I mean it was really a
jaw-dropper if he went from Budapest to
Moscow and you know and I remember one
time not to get into too many memories
but I followed around a Russian tour
group in Yugoslavia and they were just
furious and how the Yugoslavs Olivia
this is before Yugoslavia started going
down the tubes but they were furious at
the consumption level and they said boy
you know I mean they were essentially
saying you know we should have left the
block to that was it they played this
one right so so there were a lot of
there was a lot of I would say I'm
telling tales out of school but there's
a lot of insularity in Soviet studies it
was a big field of studying a superpower
we were setting the other new big
nuclear power etc and that put them in a
much more difficult I think position for
imagining a very different set of
scenarios in terms of political economic
social regime trajectories let alone
relations of these states to to the
international system let me say it
nothing now turn to it I guess I was
supposed to do the most of which is to
say post communism and talk a little bit
about that and and and how we've done
things obviously one of the things
that's been a huge shock is we now have
too much data you know it doesn't seem
right that we should have gone from too
little to too much and it has been for
many of us unbelievably overwhelming we
used to rely on on the official media
and statistical reports and sometimes
depending on
where we were working we could also do
some interviews and we could link with
some sociologists now we have all this
stuff this public opinion and we
actually have decent social and economic
data the problem in during the Communist
period is that the economic data were
very bad and you always had to put in
sentences whenever you were working from
it to apologize that you're well i'm
working with it but i know it stinks and
then you the logical question is then
why'd you work with it well it you know
it's the drop looking for the light you
know that you know the key under the
light um it's very you worked with what
you had you tried to make heroic
assumptions about let's reduce the
growth rate by twenty percent let's
figure out that they have these problems
of double County and etc but suddenly
now we have among other things the
transition to real statistics real
economic and social statistics which are
just not as transition that's not fully
completed but one of the interesting
things about EU accession of course is
that there's a huge of radical
transformation in the statistical
systems and how data are collected and
the quality of the data and and like
what if we worked on under post
communism I think I think that we're all
confronting in some ways you know one
very fascinating question and this
follows in the former Soviet Union you
rage a case too this was in a lot of
ways other one doesn't want to overstate
it a relatively homogeneous system under
communism there's a limited number of
states they follow the Stalinist model
which had developed in the Soviet Union
Yugoslavia obviously diverged from there
to certain degree but in many ways they
kept with some certain kinds of issues
certain times of structural things and
what happened of course is that suddenly
you know we had 27 now 29 cases on
Kosovo Montenegro have added since the
early breakup we have all these cases
um and what we find is huge huge
diversification of the region in a way
that really caught us by surprise now
the source of that diversity of the
region and here I'm talking about the
entire space including the former Soviet
Union the sources of that are multiple
and we should be clear about it when
these states broke up that is
Czechoslovakia it's not so relevant
there yes Yugoslavia yes the former
Soviet Union the spatial variation
socioeconomically linguistically
ethically blah blah blah of course was
highlighted in advertised you know
Tajikistan is one of the poorest
countries in the whole space it was not
that noticeable when there was a Soviet
Union similarly if you look at macedonia
vs slovenia in the former Yugoslavia so
part of it is simply a steak break up
issue that as you multiplies your cases
you highlighted the extremes in a way
you know and this suppose with party
developments goes with all other
variables I'm just using economics and
things that's a kind of convenient
example so that happened but the second
thing that happened which is really
interesting is that it turned out that
these different entities were very
differently set up to move in certain
directions I'll put it straight
forwardly no one I don't think maybe
Mike disagree with me but no one
imagined that Poland would not go
Democratic I mean I mean that was a no
brainer but I don't know if Mike what I
was shocked it not only went stayed
flowered consolidated boom boom it was
the speed of the new democracies that
really stunned me not that they would go
in that direction but that there would
be such an amazingly successful
transition as well as with capitalism I
I was stunned by the speed of the
so-called winners of the transition the
success cases so one of the things that
happened in the region is it
places really took off in terms of
democracy and capitalism thereby
creating again an extreme and that's
been what we've been interested in in
other cases when commies collapsed most
of the region was what we call hybrid
regimes I don't know if any of you
familiar with that but this is a new
kind of regime that has popped up during
the third wave of democratization all
the reality by our Germany was a hybrid
machine but anyway it's only been
written about over the past 20 years and
these are regimes that are these weird
combinations of democracy and
dictatorship in other words they don't
go for one of the other but they
straddle what does that mean in practice
well they often have authoritarian
leaders they often don't have fully rule
of law they often have competitive
elections but it's not on an even
playing field so that some sets of
players are favored over other sets of
players so you have this big gray zone
if you imagine democracy and
dictatorship you have this big gray zone
where the quote Adam divorce key for
example you know there's no fundamental
consensus on the political rules of the
game there's not one game going on
there's a mixture of political games
going on some of which are democratic
and some of which are authorities this
kind of business makes sense okay okay I
can't tell from you thank you for
naughty yeah so so what happened when
communism collapsed and at that point
after state dissolution end of 1992
there were 27 cases in the region a
majority were these mixed regimes and
they weren't really fully democratic but
they weren't really holy authoritarian
they had electoral competition but it
wasn't really quite right you know civil
liberties and political rights but they
weren't always respected etc so there
was this funny amalgam that when I in
what's happened since then politically
let me just say a little bit
economically the democracies and I was
surprised by this I don't know if others
were the democracies went to capitalism
pretty quickly and pretty effectively
even if we could talk about the various
costs to it but that process which we
thought would blow
out democracy because of the kinds of
costs that it necessarily incurred
didn't happen the hybrid regimes like
Russia for example these mixed regimes
in the 90s they ended up doing various
kinds of transition economic transitions
but basically they had the worst
economic disasters of anybody and then
the regimes that basically never noticed
the communism collapsed you know like
this many the Central Asian regimes
Belarus um to some degree Ukraine but
that's complicated you know they were
doing okay early on and so you had any
way this this interesting kind some
dictatorships lots of these mixed
regimes and sub democracies and so what
we've done and looking at the
relationship how that has affected
issues of social mobility relations
between groups how this affected issues
of economic reform economic performance
and the like so that's been one set of
questions is trying to figure out
relatedly why these mixed regimes tip in
certain directions why does Russia
become an authoritarian regime you know
by the end of the 90s why did the tip
more democratic um why did some regimes
tip in a more democratic direction you
have to have been mixed which is
actually Ukraine's example and they're
bunch of examples we could give so
looking at these regime transitions has
been a big issue the second big issue
obviously is the struggle over
identities and boundaries and and we
have spent a huge amount of many many
many studies of this I would say that
that was the issue in which many social
scientists finally discovered the region
I wanted to say something parenthesis
it's kind of interesting on the
University I matt has a very huge
contingent of development studies people
and I have been yelling for 20 years
that the post-communist Europe and
Eurasia does do develop
and they are developing places d
developing whatever you want to call
them they are actually candidates for
study the Cold War geography just like
the study of authoritarianism runs very
deep it's really striking you know I
keep saying well why not kazakhstan go
you know why not whatever so it's an
interesting kind of thing that's
happened in the study of post communism
is that I would argue that the
integration in terms of research
definition the field bringing new people
in cross-regional Study Center those of
us in the field have failed to in effect
reintegrate this region with a larger
set of studies that is somewhat less
true and Eastern and Central Europe
insofar as you talk about things like
European studies EU studies and the like
but it's very striking to me how
segmented we still remain in in so many
ways it's an interesting to talk about
why that has happened but it's really
it's really a huge issue um okay the
other thing I wanted to mention is that
and then maybe I'll stop there um open
it up is that there has been the field
of eastern and central european studies
has been radically transformed by young
scholars and it's been for me a very
very exciting period in the last 20
years watching this I don't think it's
so exciting when I write all the
ten-year letters um I think it's very
not exciting and all that I mean we've
all had this experience I'm sure it's
just unbelievable how many people there
are in the field now and many people
ended up and this is interesting I don't
know if is it true but I have a feeling
that there is now more equality between
people working on Eurasia and eastern
and central europe in terms of numbers
I'd like the curious to see if that
true but I fake it they're certainly
there closer in terms of numbers and
part of that simply is because I think
Eastern and Central Europe offered such
a rich array of research agenda
possibilities and the second thing is
that in many cases they had social
scientists with whom external scholars
could connect especially Poland Hungary
and the former Yugoslavia some degree
the Czech Republic too and that was a
real draw and the former Soviet Union
really was much weaker in that regard
because the collapse of the Soviet Union
was also a crisis for scholars within
the Soviet Union and the kinds of work
they did the definition of the research
institutes and the like so that was a
huge ship I'm gonna stop there enough
yeah